[Music]
humans know the surprising pricks of a
needle the searing pain of the stubbed
toe and the throbbing of a toothache we
can identify many types of pain and have
multiple ways of treating it but what
about other species how do the animals
all around us experience pain it's
important that we find out we keep
animals as pets they enrich our
environment we farm many species for
food and we use them in experiments to
advance science and human health
animals are clearly important to us so
it's equally important that we avoid
causing an unnecessary pain for animals
that are similar to us like mammals it's
often obvious when they're hurting but
there's a lot that isn't obvious like
whether pain relievers that work on us
also help them and the more different an
animal is from us the harder it is to
understand their experience how do you
tell whether a shrimp is in pain snake a
snail in vertebrates including humans
pain can be split into two distinct
processes in the first nerves and the
skin sent something harmful and
communicate that information to the
spinal cord their motor neurons activate
movements that make us rapidly jerk away
from the threat this is the physical
recognition of harm called nociception
and nearly all animals even those with
very simple nervous systems experience
it without disability animals would be
unable to avoid harm and their survival
would be threatened the second part is
the conscious recognition of harm in
humans this occurs when the sensory
neurons in our skin make a second round
of connections via the spinal cord to
the brain there millions of neurons in
multiple regions create the sensations
of pain for us this is a very complex
experience associated with emotions like
fear panic and stress which we can
communicate to others but it's harder to
know exactly how animals experience this
part of the process because most of them
can't show us what they feel however we
get clues from observing how animals
behave wild hurt animals are known to
nurse their wounds make noises to show
their distress and become reclusive in
the lab scientists have discovered that
animals like chickens and rats will self
administer pain reducing drugs if
they're hurting animals also avoid
situations where they've been hurt
before which suggests awareness of
threats we've reached the point that
research has made us so sure that
vertebrates recognize pain that it's
illegal in many countries to needlessly
harm these animals but what about other
types of animals like invertebrates
these animals aren't legally protected
partly because their behaviors are
harder to read we can make good guesses
about some of them like oysters worms
and jellyfish these are examples of
animals that either at lack a brain or
have a very simple one so an oyster may
recoil when squirted with lemon juice
for instance because of nociception but
with such a simple nervous system it's
unlikely to experience the conscious
part of pain other invertebrate animals
are more complicated though like the
octopus which has a sophisticated brain
and is thought to be one of the most
intelligent invertebrate animals yet in
many countries people continue the
practice of eating live octopus we also
boil live crayfish shrimp and crabs even
though we don't really know how they're
affected either this poses an ethical
problem because we may be causing these
animals unnecessary suffering scientific
experimentation though controversial
gives us some clues
tests on hermit crabs show that they'll
leave an undesirable shell if there's a
scuffle activity but stay is it's a good
shell and octopi that might originally
curl up an injured arm to protect it
will risk using it to catch prey
that suggests that these animals make
value judgments around sensory input
instead of just reacting reflexively to
harm meanwhile crabs have been known to
repeatedly rub a spot on their bodies
where they've received an electric shock
and even sea slugs flinch when they know
they're about to receive a noxious
stimulus that means they have some
memory of physical sensations we still
have a lot to learn about animal pain as
our knowledge grows it may one day allow
us to live in a world where we don't
cause pain needlessly
you
[Music]